abone ol
[Müzik]
e
Herkese merhabalar hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
Bunca zamandır düşünüyorum nasıl bir TED
konuşması yapmalıyım diye motivasyonel
bir konuşma mı olsun bilgi veren bir
konuşma mı olsun Mesaj kaygılı bir
konuşmam olsun Başka bir şey mi olsun bu
anlamda diğer tek konuşmalarına baktım
TED konuşmaları ki yalan antet
konuşmalarına baktım hepsinde temel bir
özellik keşfettim Çok güzel sözlerle
başlıyorlar konuşmaları
eski bir matematikçi olarak ben de belki
güzel bir sayıyla başlayabilirim diye
düşündüm kök 2
karekök 2
Ama bu rakam size ne ifade ediyor
Bilmiyorum ama benim hayatımı değiştirdi
görüyorum ki bütün insanlığın Aslında
hayatını değiştirmiş nasıl olduğunu
anlamak için Dilerseniz hep birlikte
Pisagor Okulu zamanlarına bakalım o
dönemler Din adamlarının günlerinin
büyük bir kısmını matematik ve Felsefe
ile geometri ile geçirdiği dönemler ve
Kumsal gördüklerinde sadece kumdan
kaleler yapmıyorlar mış bayağı çubukla
kumsala şekiller çizerek fikir
tartışmalarında bulunuyor varmış Bir
tanesi bir birim kenar uzunluğunu olan
bir kare çizmiş bir diğeri Bakmış bir
tane köşegen çizmiştir genel bu kare
kenarı bir birim köşegen kaç birim
ama bakmışlar ki ifade edemiyorlar öyle
bir sayı o sırada yok doğal sayı değil
bu kesirle ifade edemiyorlar öte bir şey
olsaydı insan hakkının o zaman ötesinde
bir sayı ve İrrasyonel sayı demişler
Buna hakkın ötesinde aklınızın almadığı
şeklinde bir bilgi daha vereyim biz hala
daha kök 2'nin tam olarak ne olduğunu
bilemiyoruz Yani iki artı iki eşittir
4'tür diye çok kolay geçiyoruz ya çok
iki artık yok iki nedir
çok kötü ki hala daha 10 trilyon
basamağına kadar biliyoruz sonsuza kadar
devam ediyor Çünkü
dahası sadece Akli bilgiyle değil bu
anlamda bütün bilgisayarları kullanalım
gene bir limitimiz var zaten bu nedenle
benim için hayranlık sebebiydi Çok kolay
çok basit bir şekilde hem içinde
Bulunduğunuz teknolojinin hem Aklımızın
bir yanda çok basit bir kavramlı sınırın
ortaya koyuyordu
bu matematikle Bu anlamda uğraşırken
dünyayı değiştiren bir başka matematikçi
ile karşılaştım John Nash LV önce
eserleriyle karşılaştırın oyunlar
kuramını gördüm Çok hayran kaldım
sonrasında 2012 yılında da bizzat
kendisini tanıma şerefine nail olduk
dünya benim çevirip Konferansı Kongresi
İstanbul'da yapıldı 2012 yılında ve
bende şununla görevlendirildi Mora bir
sürü insan şimdi John işte fotoğraf
çekmek isteyeceksen bir şekilde hem ona
yardımcı ol hem insanlar fotoğraf
çekebilirsin hem de canlı şey de çok
fazla yormayalım her gün yanındayım
ailesiyle beraber in Bir hafta önce
birlikte vakit geçiriyoruz içten içe
hissediyorum ya ben de fotoğraf çekmek
istiyorum c15m de nasıl soracağım ve hiç
beklemediğim bir şey oldu Bir gün bir
sabah tam doğunun konuşmacı olduğu gün
beraber arabaya bindik dedi ki bu ara
Seninle fotoğraf çekilelim mi havaları
ve bu sevinçten Koskoca 15 benimle
fotoğraf çekmek istiyor nasılsın için
nasıl büyük bir gurur sonra ara film
aklıma geldi 15 sadece matematik
dünyasında Ve üstelik ekonomiye yaptığı
katkılardan 1994 yılında Nobel İktisat
Ödülü'nü almış birisi değildir aynı
zamanda Hani anlatsak Hayatı film olur
değiliz ya anlatılmıştır hayatı O da
Oscar Ödülü almıştır Ebru tutulmayan
filmiyle Türkçesi Akıl Oyunları diye
geçer şimdi o filmden öğreniriz ki onun
için hayat Aslında zorluklarla geçmiş
kendi aklının oyunlarıyla baş etmeye
çalışmıştı 15 çok büyük bir süre işte
film aklına gelince Şunu fark ettim
yanlış film ve fotoğraf çekilirken Ben
Acaba onun için bir hayali arkadaşıyım
Bir haftadır vakit geçirdiği yoksa
gerçek bir karakter miyim Bunu teyit
etmek için kanıta ihtiyaç duymuş
böyle olunca Aklımızın sınırları ne
gerçek Bu nasıl ispatlayabiliriz Neyin
hayır olup olmadığını neyin gerçek
olduğunu bu sorularda daha da çok
ilgilenmeye karar verdim oyun teorisi
üzerine çalıştım oyun tedavisinde B
hepinizi bütün dünyayı etkileyen bir
takım sorunların temel sebeplerini
gösteren örneklerle karşılaştırıp
buradan başlayalım Öncelikle Bizler bir
şekilde gözlerimize güveniriz bireysel
Bilge de güveniriz bilimde de Bu
empirizmin bir anlamda zaferiyle
rasyonalizme karşı dönem dönem çok öne
çıkarılmıştır zaman zamanda rasyonel
izin daha öne çıkarılmıştır ama çok
basit örnekler bize bir şey güvenirken
dikkatli olmamız gerektiğini söyler ilki
Optik ilizyonlar hatırlarsanız sosyal
medyada bir kıyafet üzerine dünya ikiye
bölündü bu sarı mı gözüküyor mavi mi
gözüküyor başka bir renkle gözüküyor
diye dolaşır gözlerimizi o kadar da çok
güvenmemiz gerektiğini biliyoruz ama
aklımıza da aslında o kadar ve temiz
gerektiğini bazen unutuyoruz aklımızda
ilizyonları var ve sadece onun için
yaşadığı tarzında sanrılar vesaire
üzerinde değil
aklınızın Kendinizi çok iyi hissetmeye
yönelik bir takım saldırıları var mesela
en iyi bildiğimizi düşünebiliriz bazen
akıllı Biz olduğumuzu düşünüyoruz oyun
teorisindeki en çarpıcı en özet
bilgilerden bir tanesi mahkumlar
açılması ile açıklanır bakın açması
kabaca şunu söyle rekabetçi bir ortamda
yaşıyoruz bir iş yapacağız ya da bir
paylaşım probleminiz var ortada bir
pastalar iki seçeneğimiz olsun ya bir
şekilde birinci davranıp hastanın
dilimini hemen almak isteyeceğiz ya da
jest yapıp biraz da fedakarlık yapıp
karşımızdakine bir pay verilmesini
isteyeceğiz ve bu herkes için geçerli
buradaki açmaz şurada Bir ekonomide
tanım rasyonel biri için kendi çıkarını
maksimize eden birey üzerine yapılır
Dolayısıyla oyunlar kuramının mahkumları
açması der ki bu Bu kez önce kendi
çıkarını düşünür hele tanımadığı bir
kimseye güvenme falan yapmayın mümkün
değil sonuç kendi çıkarını maksimize
etmeye çalışanlar Benim de sonunda daha
küçük bir pasta dilimi ile getirmeye
çalışıyorlar ya da tersinden söyleyelim
Bence daha çarpıcı Siz Başkalarına aynı
ortamda aynı amaç için uğraştığını Hatta
rekabet ettiğiniz kişileri jestler de
bulunursanız o pasta dilimi büyüyor bu
açmazsan çıkmanın Dolayısıyla iki tane
temel kuralı var 1 sadece bugünkü
karınızı değil geleceği düşünmek diğeri
de karşı tarafla güvene baya bağlı
güvene dayalı işbirliği yapabilmek
niyetinde olmalı bütün bunlarla
uğraşırken bir süre sonra mekanizma
tasarımı teorisi ile ilgilenmeye
başladım Çünkü fark ettim ki içinde
bulunduğumuz pek çok şey bir mekanizma
aslında yani çalıştığınız kurumu olan
ilişkimiz mekanizma Mücahide sistemleri
birer mekanizma kurumların çoğu birer
mekanizma ve seçim sistemleri bir
mekanizma var şu anda çok önemli bir
teori vardır sosyal seçim teorisi
içerisinde bireylerin farklı
tercihlerinin nasıl en iyi şekilde
yansıtır alabileceğini üzerine bir
literatürü döner Bu konuda bir çalışma
yapmak için de seni 2016 Kaliforniya'da
birden fazla konunun halk oylamasına
sunuldu bir referans da var izde hocamla
beraber bu konuda bir yeni Dizayn
ettiğimiz dijital oynama sistemini
denedik
denemenin sonucu Benim bilgisayarımda 35
bin kişinin seçmen datası var 35 bin
kişi o dönem doktora sonrası araştırmacı
yum New York'ta sürekli Metro
kullanıyorum yağmur yağıyor Bilgisayarım
eksik şunu sorguluyorum bu kadar önemli
veri benim elimde durmamalı Benim
bilgisayarımda olmamalı kime emanet edin
Hocama sordum Hocam dedi ki sen daha iyi
anlarsın teknolojiden sende olsun
üniversite sınavına yüklesem O da riskli
sonra fark ettim ki bizim bütün
verilerimiz aslında bir yerlerde gayet
de buna benzer bir riske tutuluyor bu
Ama internetin yapısı nasıl diye
düşünmeye başladık Hepiniz şu anda
sayıyoruz ve 10 ve 20 ve 30 böyle futbol
maçı izliyor musun gibi geliyor sürekli
borcu var ama golü atan biz miyiz Yoksa
biz golü yiyen miyiz biz ne kadar
üreticisi yiz bütün bu ve birkaç sıfırın
ve sonra biraz baktığımızda biraz
tarihini hatırladığımız şunları görürüz
gw10 aynı televizyon izleyicisi gibi
çalışmış aslında bir yerlerde bir içerik
sağlayıcısı var Bunu da tüketimi var
yazan var okuyan var Baran ve 90'lar
sonra Bu değişmeye başlamış 2000'li
yıllarda ne olmuş artık sosyal medya
platformları oluşmuş insanların da
yazabildiği Platformu ön plana çıkmış
ama hemen akabinde başka bir şey olmuş
ve 120 da bu hükümranlık lar kurulmuş
dev şirketler uzatıcı verileriyle
beraber bir takım köşe başlarını
tutmuşlar Üstelik sizin verdiğiniz ise
bu mahrem Bilgilerinizi bununla beraber
kullanıcı deneyimlerinizi toplayıp
analiz edip başka firmalara da reklam
satıcıları için satmışlar Aslında
hepimiz mobil telefonlardan çok daha
hızlı bir şekilde bağlanıp her türlü
içeriğinizi yüklüyoruz ya bu işte onlar
sadece bir sizin vakit geçirdiğiniz
eğlenceli anlardan ibaret değil Sizin
vaktinizi nakli değeri var
Bununla beraber Aslında 2008 senesinden
itibaren bu dünyanın bu kadar Dünyanın
ekonomik aktivitelerinin mevcut para
politikalarıyla ya da millet iktisadi
kurumlarıyla yürüyemeyeceğin fark ederek
ten 2008 senesinde satışına komandonun
yazdığı Bitcoin with fırını biliyoruz
Biz ve bu aslında bir çağırır şunun
çağrısı değilim elbirliğiyle
merkeziyetsiz bir sistemi yani sizlerin
katılımcı olduğu bir dünyayı birlikte
inşa edelim ve buranın ilkeleri çok mu
bu burası Mesela açık kaynak kodlu ve 10
ünitelerini kas ediyoruz ve 30 data DC
açık kaynaklı kodlu işler yürümüyor
bununla beraber dileyen Herkes
merkeziyetsiz bir dünyayı ligte inşa
ediyor Bununla birlikte çok önemli
sloganlar var mesela Eser yuma
baktığımızda 2015 senesinden itibaren
burada artık merkeziyetsiz Özerk
kurumlar inşa edilmiş organizasyonlar
inşa edilmiş çok önemli de bir
sloganları var pod kanun dur ve bu kanun
ve bu kod müzikte yazılıyor Bu işte
buradan bir anda o web 20 da ki de
firmalarında dönüşüm geçirdiğini
görüyoruz Facebook adını Meta yaptığı
Twitter asıyoruz işi gücü bıraktı blok
ya yeni bir oluşum kurdu bunun içinde
ödeme sistemleri var Müzik firması var
müzik prodüksiyonu yapan bir firma var
Bununla beraber son haber microsoftan
biliyorsunuz 69 milyar dolarak bir oyun
fil bu kalmıştır Makro soldu 69 milyar
dolar Venezuela'nın bir senelik Gayri
safi milli hasılasının daha yüksek bırak
al iki ne oluyor dünya dönüşüyor belli
dijital dünyada yeni bir şeyler inşa
ediliyor O da belli Peki biz
neresindeyiz bunun çoğunlukla son
dönemde haberlerde en Eskileri duyuyoruz
Metafor su duyuyoruz Elif ki dediğimiz
şeyler Aslında
Sizler Dilediğiniz şekilde herhangi bir
üretimde bulunduğunuzda yazı bu video
telif hakkı içeren bir eser herhangi bir
proje bir start-up artık bunları
ben nelere mal olabilmesi için fon
bulabilmesi için aracı kurumlara gerek
kalmaksızın işin telif hakkının
eleştirilere
dayandırıldığı işin güvenme sisteminin
blok şeyine affedildiği bir dünya
kuruluyor en eskilerle meteoroloji
üzerinden burada yenisolak yok artık Bir
tanesi şu kod sanattır bir diğeri
tasarım hep bir Bunlar büyük sözler
bunlar çok önemli dünyayı
dönüştürebilecek çapta farklı bir
kültürel akımın farklı bir düşüncenin
farklı bir işbirliği yapısının
sloganları Dolayısıyla çoğumuzun duyduğu
gibi meteor söyle arsa alınan bir yer
değil bundan ibaret değil dikkat edin
arsa almadı bile hani ben arsayı alayım
birileri üzerine bir şey inşa ederse
Buralar değerlenir yaklaşımı var Bilakis
metal işte Sizler bizzat eserleriniz de
var olmak için bulunmalısınız
meteoroloji bu şekilde büyüyen bir alan
biraz tanımına bakalım Meteoroloji nedir
metaya bakalım Öncelikle çoğunlukla
Türkçeye meteor su Biz öteki Evren diye
çeviriyoruz ya da evrenin Ötesi öte
Evren gibi kelimelerle çeviriyoruz met
aynı zamanda kendine referans veren bir
kelimedir yani metadata dediğimiz en
sonunda atasıdır Dolayısıyla metaverse
Aslında evrenlerin evlenilir mi
evrenlerin evreni bu ne evrenlerde Uyu
Evrenler artık dijital dünyada bizim
bütün deneyimlerinizi aktardığımız bütün
yaşantımızı yeniden şekillendirildiği
miz köşe başları tutulmamış sınırları
çizilmemiş zamandan ve Mekandan Azade
olabilecek şekilde insanların kendi
eserlerini bir araya koyup bunu değer
paylaşımı ortak yapabildiği bir yer
mesela
görsün işte Tam burada Artık yeni bir
dünyada da şunu sormamız gerekiyor
buz ne metabo ste
Görünen köy kılavuz istemez demişler
görünen metal olsun kılavuzu
disiplinlerarası bilgi uzmanlık
araştırmak matematik Finans hukuk sanat
ve çok farklı alan bunların bir şekilde
iyi kullanım üzerine burada eserler inşa
ediliyor bu Bu beğenme ters var oranın
rehberleri günü de diyorum ki eser
bırakmak isteyen işbirliği kültürüyle
mahkumlar açmasından kaçan bununla
beraber
TOKİ'nin Akın ötesinde ve teknolojinin
ötesinde ki sinirlerini bilen ve
buralarda serüvene katılmak isteyen
cesaret sahibi kişilerin olduğu Sizler
olacaksınız umuyorum hep birlikte
meteorolojide buluşuruz Çok teşekkürler
Bera